[Musique]
c'est bientôt les vacances et à vous les
grandes balades et les heures de
farniente avec l'hymne à des bandits
qu'un et si vous en profitiez aussi pour
lever le nez et observer les quelques
bestioles à plumes qui tournoient
anciennes j'ai eu la chance de revenir
passer un peu de temps en france et
l'idée m'est venue de vous proposer une
vidéo estivale qui pourra peut-être vous
être utile si vous partez à l'aventuré
cet été je prends des cinq rapaces
diurnes très facile à observer en
métropole et pour cause certains sont
même visible depuis l'autoroute mais
avant de vous lancer dans un safari
photo endiablé quelques conseils les
rapaces sont souvent assez timide
vis-à-vis de l'humain autant que
possible ils préfèrent garder leurs
distances pour les observer plus
facilement ne fait pas trop de bruit
nanteau n'est pas votre chanson favorite
à pleine voix et limitez vos gestes au
strict nécessaire
n'hésitez pas les bras inutilement ils
peuvent prendre peur et s'envoler avant
même que vous n'ayez le temps de sortir
vos jumelles garder à l'esprit qu'ils
ont une vue excellente et qu'ils vous
ont probablement vu approcher de loin
avant même que vous ne les ayez rhdp
si vous avez la chance de tomber sur
annie occuper ce qui est encore possible
en juillet si les zozos on fait une
deuxième compte ne dérangeait rien
laisser les petits tranquille et surtout
ne les nourrit c'est pas ça vaut
d'ailleurs pour n'importe quel animal
sauvage contentez-vous d'observer sans
intervenir bien souvent nos actions des
conséquences insoupçonnées qui peuvent
mettre en danger les animaux que nous
voulions pourtant aidé c'est le cas par
exemple des jeunes chouettes et hiboux
qui ont quitté le nid me sont encore
incapables de voler non ils ne sont pas
abandonnés par les parents c'est juste
le déroulement normal de leur
développement il faut les laisser sur
place à présent que tout est dit prenez
votre crème solaire votre carnet de
terrain favori et vos jumelles et c'est
parti
[Musique]
et nous allons commencer avec un oiseau
tellement commun qui n'est pas rare de
le voir sur le bord des routes la buse
variable ce grand rapace au corps trapu
généralement un plumage brun assez
variable il peut être brun clair on voir
même tiré sur le noir avec souvent le
dos plus sombre que le ventre les pâtes
et le bec par contre sont toujours jaune
pour l'observer shr simple elle est
souvent postés sur le bord des routes
posé sur un piquet attendant la
prochaine charogne la buse variable est
un oiseau très opportuniste elle
n'hésite pas à profiter des animaux
écrasés par les voitures jeu plus simple
que d'aller chasser
pensez à regarder les bordures de champs
depuis la route seule ou et piqué sont
assez large pour accueillir un rapace
vous y verrez régulièrement de grosses
oiseaux brin poster comme des
sentinelles indifférent au bruit des
voitures ce sont des buses variables
attendant leur prochain repas mais si
son territoire n'inclut pas de route
suffisamment fréquenté pour procurer les
carcasses à volonté et il a chassé mulot
campagnols et autres petits mammifères
qui peuplent nos campagnes dans ce cas
elle s'installera en hauteur sur une
branche l'oeil pointé vers le sol
attendant qu'une preuve bien se montrait
pour lui tomber dessus tout sert dehors
[Musique]
le faucon crécerelle est devenue célèbre
depuis que quelques couples sont venu
nicher sur la fameuse cathédrale notre
dame en plein coeur de paris depuis
l'incendié de 2020 le faucon crécerelle
avait disparu mais un couple est revenu
s'y installer deux people ce qui a ravi
tous les zénith au locle en herbe de la
capitale ce n'est pas un hasard que les
faucons apprécié la cathédrale car c'est
oiseaux nichent habituellement sur des
parois rocheuses et les vieilles pierres
de l'édifice une offre une alternative
très satisfaisante et facilement
habitable grâce aux nombreuses cachettes
qu'ils y trouvent
dans nos campagnes le faucon crécerelle
affectionne particulièrement les petits
enrochements où il construit son nid
mais aussi les plaines où il trouve son
repas sera pas se nourrit principalement
de petits rongeurs et pour les capturer
il voilà quelques mètres au-dessus du
sol l'oeil tourner vers le bas
lorsqu'ils repèrent une proie il
s'immobilise au dessus de sa cible en
vol stationnaire c'est ce qu'on nomme le
vol en saint-esprit
pour l'observer jeter un oeil aux
bordures de champs il y sera souvent
battant frénétiquement des ailes pour se
maintenir en l'air avant de plonger
subitement sur sa proie c'est aussi
l'une des espèces de rapaces pour
lesquelles il est très simple de
différencier le mal de la femelle le mal
plus petits à la tête crise et le dos
d'un beau brun roux la femelle est plus
terne sans laquelle aux crises
[Musique]
il y a deux espèces de milan en france
métropolitaine le milan noir et le milan
royal ils sont reconnaissables alors que
enlevé semblable à celle des hirondelles
les mille ans sur l'un des seul rapaces
qui peut faire montre d'un comportement
grégaire en certaines saisons le milan
noir notamment se rassemblent en dortoir
le soir venu pendant la belle saison il
lui arrive aussi de niche et en petites
colonies le milan royal lui ne niche pas
en colonie mais se regroupent aussi avec
ses congénères en dortoirs une fois la
saison de nidification terminé les
milandes un vol très souple très
acrobatique ils peuvent aisément se
retourner sur le dos en plein vol tombé
soudainement pour remonter l'instant
d'après faire des virages très serrés en
orientant leur que d'un côté ou de
l'autre il s'adapte sans problème
beaucoup de vents et aux courants
aériens
si vous cherchez à voir des milandes
dirigez vous vers les plaines agricoles
et tout particulièrement vers les
endroits où les gens viennent d'être
fauché les mille ans hiro groupe et
profite de la coupe pour attraper les
petites proies qui se cachent et
auparavant dans les herbes hautes ou
dans les champs de céréales vous
assisterez ainsi un véritable ballet
aérien
attention toutefois à ne pas trop
traîner avant de planifier votre
excursion milanaise que ces oiseaux
migrateurs ils repartent vers l'afrique
entre la mi juillet et la fin août vous
pourrez les observer à cette occasion
volant en petits groupes utilisant
habilement les thermiques pour se
laisser porter sans effort
[Musique]
ce tout petit rapace fait à peu de
choses près la taille d'un pigeon le mal
a le dessus du corps gris ardoisé l'oeil
orange tandis que la femelle est brune
avec l'oeil jaune les éperviers sont des
chasseurs de petit oiseau très tenace
alors parfois jusqu'à poursuivre leurs
proies en courant au milieu des buissons
ils sont adeptes des milieux semi
ouverts chassant la fois dans les champs
et dans les bosquets d'arbres pas trop
serré l'épervier le rapace le plus
difficile à voir dans cette liste de par
sa petite taille et son tempérament
plutôt timide vis-à-vis de l'humain il
n'est pas aisé à trouver et sans l'oeil
aiguisé de l'ornithologue il est facile
de le confondre avec ébats avec un
pigeon justement mais ne désespérez pas
l'épervier sort régulièrement de son
brusque et favori pour s'attaquer au
patro du coup il vous suffira d'un peu
de patience et d'une bonne paire de
jumelles pour l'identifier sa technique
d'attaqué consiste à voler au ras du sol
ou à attendre caché dans un buisson pour
surprendre 7 6
[Musique]
principalement présent dans le sud de la
france dans les régions un peu escarpé
voir montagneuse le vautour fauve est un
très grand planeur une ombre gigantesque
à côté des autres oiseaux qui peine à le
suivre en altitude avec son envergure
depuis 2,2 m -cl très large il me suffit
d'étendre les bras pour se laisser
porter par les thermiques ces courants
chauds qui s'élève haut dans le ciel
quasiment ex terminé au 19e et au 20e
siècle il ne doit son salut qu'à la
création de réserves naturelles et de
mesures de protection comme la mise en
place du site de nourrissage par exemple
ce qui a permis aux quelques mails aux
populations escape et de reprendre du
poil de la bête et de coloniser à
nouveau le sud de la france pour
observer le vote au fonds qu'il faudra
passer ses vacances dans les pires
années dans les alpes ou encore au sud
du massif central dans ce qu'on nomme
les grands causses là des programmes de
réintroduction en favoriser
l'établissement une population stable de
vautours fauves le vautour fauve n'est
pas le seul vautours présent métropole
on peut aussi trouver le vautour moine
qui a plus de plumes sur le coup le
percnoptère d'égypte avec sa tête john
et son plumage blanc caractéristiques et
le gypaète barbu à uxeau petite barbiche
trop mimi la plupart de ces espèces sont
aussi présentes dans les pyrénées mais
la population est beaucoup plus réduite
statistiquement parlant si vous croisez
un vautour il ya de grandes chances
qu'il s'agisse d'un vautour fauve et pas
l'egypte
[Musique]
dernier petit rappel comme il s'agit de
rapaces toutes les espèces que je viens
de vous présenter sont intégralement
protégées par la loi française il est
interdit de détenir ou de faire commerce
de ces animaux vivant ou mort et ça vaut
aussi pour leurs jeux et leurs plumes
alors ne ramenez rien de notre escapade
ornitho à part peut-être de jolies
photos et des souvenirs plein la tête je
vous souhaite de très bonnes
observations d'oiseaux cet été et je
vous dis à bientôt pour de nouvelles
aventures avec des plumes
[Musique]
e